[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et retour ce capteur est une des grandes
chansons de l'album blanc une oeuvre
mythique des beats aux je lis usé à la
corde
j'en suis probablement ma quatrième
édition
je les racheter en mono vinyle n'ya pas
longtemps lui trente chansons de l'album
blanc passe d'un style à l'autre
ce disque éclectique a été un important
tournant pour le groupe qui se réinvente
est complètement qui dit l'un d'eux fin
c'est l'album où je pense que les quatre
ont sorti de la période mythos ont sorti
vraiment ce qu'il y avait de mieux en
eux sans grand talent bon faut souligner
le 50e anniversaire de l'album jazz
martin le fils du réalisateur john
morton a remixé les pistes en utilisant
les bandes analogiques original et les
processeurs de l'époque
et tant qu'à faire il a sorti les vôtres
près de soixante dix prises inédites
pour les inclure dans un coffret de luxe
[Musique]
en écoutant ces démos on réalise à quel
point les 4 bits aux était dans un élan
qui est extraordinaire c'est lé premier
pas
pour acculer à leur vie d'adulte en tant
qu'artiste et c'est pour ce qui est
essentiel
[Musique]
si à 76 ans paul mccartney ne peut
s'empêcher de chanter en concert
barkindo ouais ça sort est ce que dit
pas plus voudront encore pigé dans leurs
économies pour acheter un nouveau un
album qu'ils ont déjà
j'ai quelques réticences devant les
remakes les rééditions oui tout ça parce
que ça s'est un peu mercantile demandez
aux gens d'acheter ce qu'ils ont déjà
par contre avec les bills aux quand on
arrive à trouver d'autres choses
moi personnellement ça pique ma
curiosité et je suis preneur
[Musique]
cette réédition de l'album blanc
s'inscrit dans un remixage du catalogue
du béton amorcée l'an dernier avec le
disque sort john pepper
le résultat est heureux le prix n'est
peut-être un peu moins ici louis fait
des primaires
radio canada montréal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]